R
YOUR SINGLE JOHNSON & JOHNSON
SHOT.
>>> THIS MORNING, WE ARE LOOKING
AT HOW COSTS FOR THINGS LIKE
GROCERIES AND GAS ARE RISING.
AS THE ECONOMY RECOVERS FROM THE
PANDEMIC.
THE CONSUMER PRICE INDEX WHICH
MEASURES WHAT PEOPLE PAY FOR
EVERYDAY ITEMS WAS UP 4.2% IN
APRIL FROM A YEAR EARLIER.
THAT IS THE LARGEST INCREASE
SINCE SEPTEMBER OF 2008.
A RECENT SURVEY FOUND 87% OF
AMERICANS ARE VERY OR SOMEWHAT
CONCERNED ABOUT INCREASED
HOUSEHOLD EXPENSES.
CBS NEWS BUSINESS ANALYST JILL
SCHLESINGER JOINS US NOW.
JILL, SO GOOD TO SEE YOU.
I MISS YOU.
CAN'T WAIT UNTIL YOU'RE BACK IN
THE STUDIO.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
>> GOOD TO SEE YOU, AS WELL.
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING YOU
ALL.
>> SO WE ARE SEEING MANY PRICES
SURGE RIGHT NOW.
WHY ARE WE SEEING THOSE PRICES
UP?
>> INCLUDE, JILL, THE PRICE OF
BACON.
IT'S A TRAVESTY.
>> MY GOD.
WHICH IS REALLY THE MOST
IMPORTANT ASPECT OF THIS FOR
SURE.
OKAY.
I'M GOING TO JUST TRY TO BREAK
THIS DOWN A LITTLE BIT.
NOW, WHEN WE SEE INFLATION
RISING, THERE'S A FEW
CONTRIBUTING FACTORS.
I NOT THE MOST IMPORTANT -- I
THINK THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
IS WE'RE COMPARING TO A YEAR
AGO.
THAT IS WHEN THE ECONOMY WAS
SHUT DOWN AND PRICES PLUNGED.
THAT WASN'T ACTUALLY A GOOD
TIME.
OBVIOUSLY THINGS HAVE LOOSENED
UP.
SO THAT'S ONE CONTRIBUTING
FACTOR.
THE SECOND, WE'VE HAD SUPPLY
CHAIN ISSUES.
IF YOU GO BACK A YEAR, A LOT OF
THE PRODUCERS WERE BASICALLY
SAYING LET'S HALT OUR SHIPS,
LET'S MAKE SURE THAT CKCONTAINE
ARE PACKED JAMMED WITH STUFF,
AND THEY GOT CAUGHT FLAT FOOTED.
A LOT OF THE SUPPLY ISSUES
ACTUALLY WERE PROBLEMATIC,
ESPECIALLY AS OUR DEMAND FOR
GOODS STARTED TO RISE.
AS A RESULT, WE ARE SEEING
EVERYTHING RISE.
SO NOT JUST BACON, GAYLE.
IT IS APPLIANCES, IT IS
FURNITURE, IT IS NOW AIRLINE
PRICES, HOTELS, RENTAL CARS.
IT SEEMS LIKE EVERYTHING ACROSS
THE BOARD IS BECOMING MORE
EXPENSIVE, ESPECIALLY WHEN
COMPARED TO A YEAR AGO.
>> SO HOW DO YOU EXPECT THAT TO
IMPACT CONSUMERS THEN?
YOU KNOW, WE'RE JUST STARTING TO
TAKE BABY STEPS OUT THERE.
NOW EVERYTHNG IS MORE
EXPENSIVE.
THAT'S NOT GOOD.
>> IT'S NOT.
AND I THINK THE BEST EXAMPLE OF
HOW IT CAN TRICKLE DOWN QUICKLY
IS IF WE LOOK AT LUMBER PRICES.
NOW LUMBER PRICES HAVE GONE UP
BY 400% FROM A YEAR AGO.
>> WOW.
>> WHY?
BECAUSE A YEAR AGO SAWMILLS SAID
WE'RE IN THE MIDDLE OF AN
ICE-COLD RECESSION, LET'S SHUT
DOWN THE MILLS.
THEY SHUT THEM DOWN.
WHAT DID THEY NOT EXPECT?
FOR PEOPLE TO SAY, I WANT TO
REMODEL MY HOUSE, I NEED TO
BUILD AN EXTENSION, I WANT TO
BUILD A NEW HOUSE.
AS A RESULT OF LUMBER, THE PRICE
OF A NEWLY BUILT HOME, ACCORDING
TO THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
HOME BUILDERS, IS UP BY $36,000
JUST OVER THE COURSE OF THE
YEAR.
AND THE SAME THING GOES WITH
ELECTRONICS.
YOU KNOW, A LOT OF ELECTRONICS
MAKERS SAID LET'S PUT IT ALL IN
PERSONAL ELECTRONICS.
WHO KNEW THAT EVERYONE WAS GOING
TO WANT A CAR.
THE PRICE OF RENTAL CARS, NEW
CARS, USED CARS, EVERYTHING
SKYROCKETING.
THAT'S HOW IT TRICKLES DOWN.
>> JILL, WITH THE SUPPLY LINES
BACK UP AND RUNNING AGAIN NOW,
HOW LONG BEFORE WE CAN EXPECT
SOME OF THESE PRICES TO START TO
COME DOWN?
>> WELL, I MEAN, I THINK WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE A FEW MONTHS HERE
WHERE THINGS ARE GOING TO BE
RY DIFFICULT IN TERMS OF
PRICES.
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING TODAY IS,
YOU'RE RIGHT, THE SUPPLY ISSUES
HAVE TO GET RESOLVED.
EVEN IF YOU JUST LOOK AT THE
PIPELINE ISSUE, THE THING WAS
SHUT DOWN FOR A WEEK.
WE KNOW PRICES ARE GOING TO
RE-REGULATE.
THE PROBLEM IS IT TAKES A WHILE.
YOU KNOW, ESSENTIALLY ONE
ECONOMIST SAID IT'S EASIER TO
FREEZE AN ECONOMY THAN TO
DEFROST AN ECONOMY.
AND IF YOU LOOK AT JUST GAS
PRICES THEMSELVES, GAS PRICES
BEFORE THE PIPELINE UP ALMOST
50% FROM A YEAR AGO.
SO THINGS ARE GOING TO -- YOU'RE
GOING TO SEE HIGHER PRICES FOR
THE NEXT FEW MONTHS.
AND I THINK THINGS SHOULD SETTLE
DOWN BY THE END OF THE YEAR.
BUT WE ARE WATCHING THIS -- IT
IS THE MOST IMPORTANT THING ON
ECONOMISTS'S MINDS RIGHT NOW.
>> CONSUMERS ARE NERVOUS RIGHT
NOW.
THEY MAY DRIVE PRICES UP EVEN
HIGHER.
WHAT WOULD BE THE LONG-TERM
IMPACT OF THAT?
>> THAT IS NOT A GOOD SITUATION.
IT'S ACTUALLY THE THING THAT
WORRIES ECONOMISTS AND FINANCIAL
ANALYSTS THE MOST.
AND THE WEIRD THING IS THAT WE
CONSUMERS, WE HAVE A LOT OF
POWER IN THIS, BECAUSE
INFLATION, OUR EXPECTATION OF
PRICES RISING, IT CAN BE
SELF-FU
SELF-FULFILLING.
LOOK WHAT HAPPENED LAST WEEK AS
PEOPLE WERE HOARDING GAS IN THE
SOUTHEAST.
IT REALLY IS A PROBLEM.
BUT THAT SAID, IF PEOPLE THINK
PRICES ARE GOING UP OVER THE
LONGER TERM, THEN WE HAVE A MORE
DIFFICULT PROBLEM.
THEN CONSUMERS ARE GOING TO WANT
TO ASK THEIR BOSSES FOR WAGE
INCREASES.
IF THE BOSSES GIVE THEM THOSE
WAGE INCREASES, IT CAN ONLY ADD
TO INFLATION.
SO IT CAN BECOME A VICIOUS
CYCLE, ONE THAT ECONOMISTS ARE
FEARFUL OF.
>> ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
YOU YOU LOOK LIKE A SPRING
GARDEN TODAY.
THANKS A L